the young people at this support group
are like any other teenagers dealing
with the challenges of adolescent life
but they also face struggles most don't
they're transitioning to agenda they
were not born in and that means a race
against time I was constantly worrying
so much before blockers that my voice
would break or odd about really
masculine features and it was it wasn't
healthy cuz I'm just worrying so much
that was my main worry that suddenly I'd
go through puberty I wanted to come out
since I was 9 but as an any girl in the
family then noticed I'm on these little
princess and I didn't want to tarnish
that blonds had a baby girl none of what
you can do it so I did and I've been
really really happy since I just kind of
want to get it over and done with I
don't I don't want to wait any longer
than I have to because once this is over
I can live my life completely normally
like less blood tests don't have to
worry about people looking at me
Tallulah Eve Brown is a confident
transgender woman with a rising profile
in the community but one of her big
regrets is that she was unable to
transition at a younger age I think it's
like this when I was doing that I
would've transitioned when I was younger
because I would have felt more
comfortable Tuesday yeah I wouldn't have
dear adding that far and the deep boys
say yeah I wish I could have
transitioned younger sky has obtained
NHS England records which reveal it
carried out 330 gender reassignment
procedures last year since 2002 the
number of NHS male-to-female procedures
has increased by 74% there were only 17
cases involving 16 to 20 year olds but
referrals to the UK's only children's
clinic have gone up fivefold not
treating people is not a neutral act it
will result in harm there are a number
of studies around the world which
port are greatly increased prevalence of
self-harm and suicide amongst trans
people who are unable to access care
there's ongoing concern about the risks
of medical interventions for transgender
children to change sex is not possible
but we are administering cross-sex
hormones for example not cross gender
hormones and we're setting children on
the path of medication for life of very
strong off-label drugs which and
surgeries which have complications and
side effects and with sterilizing
children for life but as the agony of
life in the wrong gender continues to be
linked to depression anxiety and even
suicide these young people feel it's a
risk worth taking
fo Hirsch Sky News